[BIRDS CHIRPING]
[UPBEAT MUSIC]
BEN SORKIN: My name is
Ben Sorkin,
and I'm a senior studying
mechanical and
aerospace engineering.
This is kind of
my home to tinker
and create and
build things.
150 to 420 million gallons
of unburned gasoline
are released into U.S. waters every year
by just the pleasure-craft
industry alone.
The U.S. switching
to electric outboards
would work on completely
eliminating this number.
I want to be at the forefront
of this technology,
at the forefront
of innovation
concerning sustainable
technologies.
VIVIAN CHANG: Hi,
I'm Vivian Chang,
a second-year master's
student at Woodrow Wilson,
and we're about to
start our second
volunteer training workshop
for the Day of Action.
I think individually a lot of
people are kind of waking up.
A lot of my friends who have
never participated in protests
or don't necessarily
keep up with news about,
you know, the government
or civil rights,
are now like reading, talking,
organizing themselves,
and that's really important.
ZIA MIAN: So, my task
is say a few words about
how and why so many members
of the Princeton faculty
are here and being part of today,
and we'll also be here
tomorrow and the day after
and four years from now when
many of the students here
are gone and a new generation
of students are here.
Intellectuals, especially academics,
have the power that comes
from political liberty,
from access to information,
and freedom of expression.
We take them for granted
here, but we shouldn't.
It is the responsibility
of intellectuals
to speak the truth
and to expose lies,
and what we're trying to do here,
all the faculty
that's participating,
is to practice that responsibility.
HENRY HORN: The books here are
all about butterflies,
which is what I'm writing
about at the moment.
There are tree books
together, bird books together.
Over around behind you,
these are all individual
project boxes
for research projects or
teaching projects done or undone.
Hi, I'm Henry Horn.
I'm an emeritus,
but not so you'd notice,
professor of ecology and
evolutionary biology at Princeton,
and I've actually been
teaching here for 52 years now.
Of course, I've seen waves
of environmental concerns,
the first in the '70s
and the first Earth Day.
There was a great deal
of activity at that time,
and then it just
waned for quite a while.
I think the thing that is
missing is the long view,
the long view of history,
the long view of the future,
and notion of what
real sustainability
with humans as part of
nature is all about.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]